look but I wanted to talk about the
problems and the Solutions in other
words what are the identify the problems
in the solution we cannot ignore today's
events today when you put out your your
true social post and by that I want to
talk about what is clearly now what the
Judiciary Committee under Jim Jordan is
looking into whether or not our FBI and
our department of justice have been
weaponized and politicized and I have
two headlines here you know FBI tipped
off Biden team Secret Service about plan
to interview Hunter according to a
supervisory agent who retired tomorrow
there will be another IRS whistleblower
just like this man Mr chapley who came
out and said no he should have been
indicted on felony charges and I've been
doing this meeting Hunter Biden that I
can take you back and you know that I
covered this every single night and my
show was Vindicated on the issue of
trump Russia collusion that never
occurred the Durham report corroborated
at the Horowitz report it's a long way
of me asking this very simple basic
question and that is if you look at
Hillary Clinton and the way she was
treated no prosecutor would prosecute 33
000 subpoenaed emails deleted devices
destroyed then her dirty dossier and
that dossier was used to get four Pfizer
warrants and then you look at the FBI in
2019 they had Hunter Biden's laptop in
December of 2019. they verified it in
March of 2020 and yet FBI agents in the
months leading up to that election were
meeting with big tech companies telling
them according to Joel Roth the former
Twitter Integrity side head telling them
that it might be about Joe or hunter
that laptop story got censored the
American people would deny the truth
about what would be a bombshell story
[Applause]
meet with all of the great reporting
done and this has been some great
reporting done generally speaking the
Press is fake it's fake and it's just
horrible actually but there's still been
some great reporters and great reporting
done and you are at the lead you've been
incredible but John
when you look at that they haven't even
gotten to the bottom of the laptop they
don't want to put the pictures in they
don't want to they have pictures in
there that anybody else they go away for
10 years
what happened to Hunter is he got a
traffic ticket other people are being
sentenced to many years in jail for
doing much less he got a traffic ticket
the only good thing is the people know
it's not going to happen it's just not
going to happen now Jim Jordan and Jamie
Coleman these guys are doing a great job
but the problem is you find out the
crime but nothing happens with it
instead they go after you like for
example Hillary Clinton's home wasn't
raided Joe Biden's garage wasn't raided
the UPenn Center wasn't raided the
University of Delaware wasn't raided his
home beach home I don't know how he
affords a beach home on a senator salary
that wasn't rated Hunter Biden has been
protected obviously
cocaine in the White House 10-day
investigation they they they literally
interviewed nobody okay investigation's
over would that have happened in your
White House well well listen to this
even you mentioned the beach home well
the beach home had all these documents
in it right it was by the Corvette
they're on the floor classified
documents oh that's not the bishop now
the beach home was another place this is
also the beach shop and they had the
Corvette where they had the Corvette and
a tremendous amount of payment was made
for That Home by somebody to Joe Biden
and it was a big story for about one day
and then you don't hear about it anymore
it's incredible but when you look at the
documents all over the place whatever
happened to that one they go after me on
documents and I have the presidential
records act which is a big deal and the
presidential records Act is a is is an
act
why weren't their homes rated well let
me just tell you I'm protected by
Presidential records act and they come
up with this obscure crazy Theory a
Madman Theory this guy is a deranged
prosecutor who's had tremendous failures
all over the place he's a nasty horrible
human being they come after me now they
have Biden has many thousands I mean
he's got 2 000 almost 2 000 boxes of
documents they can't get to him because
the college or whatever that has them
doesn't want to give him but and he
probably told the college but more
importantly China gives millions of
dollars to UPenn that's where he has
some he's got them all over the place
and maybe worst of all he's got
documents in Chinatown in Chinatown many
many documents boxes of documents you
don't ever hear about this all you hear
about is Trump and I'm totally covered
by the presidential records act and also
by the Clinton Sox case you know what
that is that's what Clinton took out
tapes and it sucks and he put him in his
drawer and they sued him just on a very
civil basis and he ended up winning the
lawsuit and the judge said he can have
whatever he wants and that's called the
presidential record what about Sandy
Burger shoving documents down his pants
oh there are many instances of it but
especially when you're president and Joe
Biden wasn't president you're only
covered by the presidential records act
if you're President Joe Biden wasn't
president in fact Joe Biden was Senator
for many years and they've got a lot of
classified documents when he was Senator
and other Democrat Senators can't even
believe the fact that he has these
documents can't even they said I watched
Dick Durbin here's another Beauty I
watched Dick Durbin saying I can't
believe that he took them I couldn't he
couldn't even believe it so it's a very
it's a two-tier system but it's worse
than that it's a very corrupt system
okay so my my question to you is when
you see that Hillary had top secret
classified information and the
conclusion of Jim Comey no prosecutor
whatever prosecute 33 000 subpoenaed
emails deleted devices destroyed okay
then we have the FBI in early October of
2016 sent agents over the pond to meet
with Christopher Steele they offered him
a million dollars to to verify any part
of that to get jumped okay they couldn't
verify it then in late October even
though it wasn't verified they used that
according to Andrew McCabe Deputy FBI
director without that dirty dossier they
would never have gotten those fiso
warrants approved now they knew that
they couldn't verify it the dura report
confirmed none of it was true and yet
they would use that as a backdoor Aspire
in your campaign and your presidency is
that a dual system of justice and the
whole thing with Pfizer was horrible but
you know one thing we did that was so
great I fired Comey very early and a lot
of people said oh you should have done
it well you know they're giving a term
let's give it a turn very early
not immediately early but very early
early in a few months and I got rid of
this guy and by doing that it was like
you threw a rock at a hornet's nest the
whole thing collapsed you saw the Love
Letters back and forth with the
different people talking about the
insurance policy you know what the
insurance policy that was against me
that was how to issue for some reason
loses darling we have an insurance
policy the insurance policies they'll
get me out one way or the other they'll
get me out because you know what this is
30 35 years of being put into government
and you get there and initially I didn't
know people in Washington I was there 17
times in my entire life I never stayed
over never stayed over before this all
of a sudden I'm president of the United
States I relate and we had tremendous
people also don't forget biggest tax
cuts in history biggest regulation Cuts
in history rebuilt our military took out
ices Cook Out salomany took out Al
baghdadi the two biggest terrorists in
the world I mean what we did was
incredible strongest border we've ever
had everything was good no inflation
best economy in history we did all of
this stuff we had tremendous we had
tremendous people look they made a lot
of money
no no so we had tremendous people but we
also had some you rely on others you
rely on people that you knew you rely on
other politicians to give you answers
and you find out that they are rhinos or
they gave you bad advice so we had some
that weren't good but when you think
Comey had a term he had many years left
in that term I said this guy's bad news
I realized it very early very early in
the administration I fired him and it
was wild that's when we found out all of
the corruption had I not fired Comey you
wouldn't know any of the things that you
were talking about you think they would
have destroyed you well they were trying
to take me out yeah they were trying to
take me out I mean it was like a coup it
was like a coup had I not you know it's
very interesting some people that are
very smart that you know very well
said when I did it oh that was a mistake
that was a mistake you're going to cause
now they say it was the greatest
instinctual move they've ever seen
because Comey was a very bad guy and
Comey LED that group of thugs in there
and they were doing a number they were
it's very dishonest it's years and years
of putting in people Democrats and
rhinos and other people but putting them
into office and we got rid of a lot of
them but we're going to get rid of a lot
more a lot more because you have some
bad
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else